こんにちははじめ社長です
と言いたいところですが今日はスペシャルゲスト呼んでおりますどうぞああっ
100です40202
1100ネイビーはあああああ
ごめん than ああああ
18万人 jackie chan というかも知れドローン
会はもう完全に以前
指たちも編集も進化を全部任せる
ブーブー意識[ __ ]ジュニョン
ちょっとそちら見ていただければ遺産富島寛徳
今日は何をするんですか
大アジめしゃちょよろしくな
これからお前らには1分間でケーキを食べ切ってもらうぞ
かあらに有働アナの最後にはビッグなお知らせがあるかあっいつも厳しいキュウーーー
ドゥ
ちょっと待ってくれ
普通に食べてもつまんないからこんな格好でダメてもらうぜ
やっていたんですか
worth ripe
これはこれつらいいけるんじゃないすか2人で協力すればこれまさにコラボですよ
キュアロードしてこれそういただければ10分かでたべき
それじゃあ行くぜ1分チャレンジスタート
加藤それ品です
方剤したのそうですよ
ブーブー
voodoo
残念
を使いして帰ればいいん
ブーバーし
じゃレンジは失敗だったなぁでも社長いい
クリっぷりだったぞ
それじゃあここで冒頭に伝えたビッグなお知らせを発表するぜ
ありがとうございます
はいりません
はいん
玄武2100円 tb のチャンネルでは始め社長が出演している
うわず左4決定戦を開い真鍮
日はすぐチェ
じゃああー
願いしまーす